Keep on rockin, Timme!
Jajajaja, das ist sie, Freak Show 168.
Für die Fans.
Für die Fans, das ist für die Fans live auf dem 32. Chaos Communication Congress. Full House, hallo willkommen.
Und, und meine 150.
Ist das so?
Haben wir so gemacht.
Echt?
Ich guck mal nach, also wenn das stimmt, das wär natürlich der Hammer.
Also dann bereite ich schon mal das Konfetti vor.
Die haben mir gerade sauber gemacht.
Ja, ja, ich muss jetzt hier, warte mal.
Sehen die das jetzt auch irgendwo?
Was denn?
Was du jetzt brauchst.
Achso, willst du?
Dass die das sehen?
Wollen wir wissen, was du brauchst?
Ist ja nicht so spannend.
Keine Ahnung, ich gucke erstmal, ich generiere erstmal die Zahlen. Und dann können wir das ja immer noch freischalten hier. Bamm, bamm, bamm, bamm, bitte warten, bitte warten. Achso, warte mal, falscher Klick.
So ist das immer.
Jaja, ihr kommt ja dann auch immer in der letzten Minute mit euren Ideen.
So ist es.
Während ich hier noch die richtige Webseite suche, kann ich ja schon mal euch vorstellen. Huckel ist da.
Hallo. Willkommen.
Und natürlich auch Dennis. Mutmaßlicher Rekordhalter.
Jaja, nach dir.
Aber das stimmt. Es ist wahr, es ist die 150. Sendung, an der du teilnimmst, Dennis.
Hammer.
Jetzt liegt das ganze Konfetti auf dem Boden. Das ist ja auch geil. Ach so, da. Jetzt liegt es auch auf dem Boden, Dennis.
Sehr schön.
Im Boden wäre es super.
Da kann ich ja in dem Zusammenhang auch noch mal ein paar andere Rekorde vermelden. Das ist ja jetzt auch nicht so schlecht. Damit bist du dann sozusagen auch schon klarer Platz 3. Max ist mit 94 immer noch mit Applaus.
Für Platz 3 gibt es keinen Applaus.
Für Roddy gibt es zumindest eine Schnapszahl. 77 hast du schon durch.
Ohje, na ja passt für den Abend, oder?
Sieht so aus.
Genau. Wie dem informierten Freak Show-Juror aufgefallen sein dürfte, ist Clemens nicht da. Wir senden einen Gruß in das Land des Freien Internets nach Schweden.
Nach Uppsala.
Wo der Herr Schrimpe, ist er da?
Keine Ahnung.
Das war irgendwas anderes. Du wirst ja wahrscheinlich zu Clemens. Hallo Clemens, ich hoffe dein Netz ist stabil und die Tanzschritte sitzen. Wir haben euch keine Themen mitgebracht.
Wie immer.
Aber unsere Bingo-Abteilung hat auf jeden Fall noch mal kräftig nachgelegt. Bitte erwartet jetzt nicht von mir, dass das von mir vollständig inhaltlich durchdrungen wurde. Aber mir wurde zugesichert, das System wurde nachhaltig verbessert. Unter anderem haben wir hier diesen Freak Show-Monitor. Und wenn sozusagen bestimmte klassische Buzzwords gefallen sind, dann sollten die hier erscheinen. Wenn nicht gerade der Bildschirm ausgeht. Was ist das denn hier? Ach, jetzt ruft Clemens an hier. Warte mal, Clemens, wo bist du denn?
Der kann es auch nicht lassen.
Ja, ja, Connecting. Ah, warte mal, halt, stopp. Also, Clemens, das Problem ist, dass ich jetzt... Warte mal, doch, wenn du jetzt was sagst. Ich weiß jetzt bloß nicht, ob irgendwie dieses beknackte... Sag mal irgendwas, Clemens.
Hören wir dich?
So gut ist das Netz in Schweden.
Na, ich hör da auf jeden Fall so ein komisches Echo. Von daher könnte es sein... Du musst irgendwas sagen, Clemens. Das ist jetzt total ungetestet. Wie macht man denn mit diesem Scheißteil eigentlich... Ja, ja, er soll mal was sagen. Sag doch mal irgendwas.
Ich gucke da raus. Aber Clemens und was sagen?
Ja, Output ist Headphone. Ah ja, so ein bisschen leise. Du musst lauter reden. Der FaceTime-Geist.
Der Klaus ist hier für euch auch, nicht nur für die Golden Webster-Bettner.
Ah, super. Kannst du mal zeigen, wo du da bist irgendwie?
Also wer nachher noch Langeweile hat, und die immer wieder auf den 32C3 abweist, der kann mal hier rüber schalten. Ich hab da ein Link gepostet.
Und Clemens beim Tanzen.
Aus irgendwelchen Gründen wird das auch irgendwie gestreamt. Ich weiß nicht warum, aber sie meint, man müsste das streamen hier.
Das heißt, wir können dich tanzen sehen.
Wie bei uns, genau.
Ja, hervorragend.
Okay, also ich wünsche euch viel Spaß. Ich wollte nur einen kurzen Gruß rüber werfen.
Alles klar, sehr modern, Clemens. Super, bis dann. Dein Applaus.
Tanz uns das Internet.
Ja, tanz uns das Internet.
Tütütütüt.
War das jetzt über IPv6?
Äh, bestimmt.
Bingo.
Sah aber mehr nach V4 aus.
IPv6 ist jetzt bei 10%.
Einen Zwischenapplaus für IPv6, unser Freund, die Zukunft.
Jawoll. Bingo.
Dennis, wie ist denn die Getränkesituation eigentlich hier?
Hier jetzt, hier so?
Ja, wir haben...
Wir haben hier nach unten eine Feedback-Schleife von unserem eigenen... Kann das sein, dass hier gerade unser Stream... Hallo, Sendezentrum? Regie, kann das sein, dass hier gerade irgendwie den Stream hier in den Mix reinlaufen lässt? Weil den höre ich nämlich im Hintergrund. Ich höre mich sozusagen mit 30 Sekunden Delay.
Gibst du mir mal den Rum?
Was wie? Den Rum?
Den Rum.
Da auch, wenn da noch nichts drin ist.
Ich weiß nicht, ob da was drin ist.
Ich hab da nichts reingemacht. Jeder macht sich seinen...
Ach so, du meinst, ich trinke die ganze Zeit einen Schunk? Ist das meiner?
Wir haben nämlich alle schon einen im Tee. Also Tim noch von gestern, Roddy vom Beer Pong, Dennis vom Forecast, Dennis vom Backstage.
Also du machst jetzt hier die Bar, und machst ja auch die Kasse. Also du arbeitest ja auch. Du machst ja auch was.
Wie letztes Jahr?
Du bist ja nicht nur so ein hedonistischer Freigeist, sondern tust ja auch was. Kannst du mal so ein bisschen aus dem Maschinenraum berichten, wie es hier so ist?
Wenig, wenig. Ich muss halt Geld zählen, im Großen und Ganzen. Weil, trotz Vorbestellung haben wir T-Shirt-Verkauf und Bar-Verkauf. Und dann muss man halt Scheine zählen und Geld rollen.
Spannend.
Und dafür sorgen, dass es sicher ist. Alter, das Buchhaltung ist total spannend.
Hast du das Thema durchdrungen?
Nee, aber es sind ja noch acht andere. Das heißt, jeder muss ein Neuntel können und insgesamt haben wir das im Griff.
Also auf neunte Buchhaltung wäre ich schon ganz stolz, wenn ich so viel dabei hätte. Jetzt gab es gerade ein bisschen den Disput, ob ein Schunk mit Flora Power oder mit Club-Mate gemixt werden sollte.
Das sollten wir auf jeden Fall tiefgründig behandeln.
Ja, dann mal los.
Für mich ist ja die Regentschaft der Club-Mate beendet. Ich weiß, das ist ein kontroverses Thema, aber für mich hat die Flora Power quasi den Thron der Maten schon längst übernommen. Man sieht sie hier im speziellen Congress-Design auch.
Ach ja, stimmt. Wie ist denn das überhaupt gekommen?
Freunde, Liebe.
Das ist eigentlich sehr geil.
Siehst du, und das alleine. In wie vielen Jahrzehnten Loscher Brauerei und tonnenweise Abnahme von Mate haben sie uns nie die Rakete drauf gedruckt.
Haben wir sie jemals danach gefragt?
Ich weiß nicht, ob wir Flora Power danach gefragt haben. Muss man Freunde extra bitten?
Aber wir hatten tatsächlich auf dem zweiten Camp auf der Rückseite der Premium Cola die Rakete drauf. Aber leider nur auf der Rückseite, weil sie auch ein bisschen lame fanden.
Aber ich muss auch sagen, jetzt wo ich den Chunk das erste Mal mit Flora Power trinke, muss ich sagen, das schmeckt mir das erste Mal seit langem wieder richtig gut.
Er ist ja auch selbst gemixt.
Das kommt noch erleichterender zu, aber im Gegensatz zu dem industriell hergestellten Chunk.
Genau.
Und natürlich, also Flora Power schmeckt einfach auch besser.
Ich hab gehört, das liegt da dann, weil die Mate hat ihre Rezept verändert. Das stimmt nicht. Nicht? Meint der Prom, kennen wir alle. Der meinte, da ist jetzt mehr Zucker drin und auch Fructose wohl.
Genau, das ist kein richtiger Zucker mehr. Es ist dieses Sirup, dieses krebserregende Sirup. Also wirklich, Club Mate, das trinkt man heute nicht mehr.
Tim, gib zu, du schmeckst einfach nichts mehr.
Bist du sicher, dass das früher nicht so war?
Keine Ahnung.
Früher war alles besser.
Aber tatsächlich Glucose-Fructose-Sirup ist hier auf Platz 2 vor Zucker.
Ja, war das früher auch schon so? Hat der mal ein Bild von 20 Jahre alten Mate? Wir haben im Berliner Club ja unser Mate-Museum.
Also es gibt bestimmt einen, ja.
Und da könnte man mal gucken. Aber Berliner Club ist jetzt tot, da ist keiner.
Stimmt.
Aber die Mate, die Flora Power, lebt. Wer von euch, kurze Hörerumfrage, Hand hoch, wer ist für Flora Power? Okay, wer ist für Club-Mate?
Ich würde schon sagen, da liegt was im...
Hat sich jetzt keiner mehr getraut.
Also, ich gehe ja voll mit, was deine Analyse betrifft, so generell, und ich finde, insbesondere ist die Flora Power hervorragend als Long-Drink-Kombination.
Aber? Aber? Aber?
Der Chunk ist ja schon ein eigenes Wesen. Und...
Aufzucht und Hege.
Ja, und der macht ja nicht nur breit. Sondern der erfrischt ja auch.
Ja, das tut mein Flora Power Chunk aber auch schon.
Ja, und wenn ich das noch mal kurz zitieren darf, der prickelnde Mate Eistee, erfrischend, aktiv, erfrischend und aktiv. Und ich glaube, irgendwo stand noch was anderes.
Du kannst aber claim von Realität unterscheiden, oder?
Also ich finde sozusagen, dass der höhere Kohlensäureanteil im Chunk ein Vorteil ist.
Also gestern in der Bar schon im nicht Vollrausch, aber Semirausch hat auch einer tatsächlich das Argument für die Club-Mate genannt und meinte, die klatscht mehr im Chunk.
So kann man es auch formulieren.
Ja, so ins Gesicht oder auf die Geschmacksknospen. Also ich muss ja sagen, damals das erste Mal im Club, im CCCB das erste Mal Mate trinken, dachte ich, das schmeckt wie Schiffsspülwasser mit Zwieback oder irgendwie sowas. Also so will man nicht trinken. Dann habe ich es ein zweites Mal probiert, weil natürlich alle coolen Nerds um mich rum weiterhin diese Mate getrunken haben, obwohl ich es gar nicht verstanden habe. Und dann war es so, naja, gar nicht mal so scheiße. Und dann habe ich es ein drittes Mal getrunken und.
Also, da muss man mal reinfassen ins Rohr.
Das hat so ein bisschen was von…
Java programmieren? Na komm, was für Tiere verartest du denn?
Wenn der Tierarzt zur Kuh kommt, dann zieht er erstmal einen sehr langen Handschuh an.
Vielleicht musst du ins andere Loch fassen.
Nee, das Ding steckt einfach fest. Schau mal die Störungsstelle an.
Die soll einfach mal ein bisschen Druck drauf geben.
Störungsstelle, genau.
Aber das Ding wurde gerade umgeroutet.
Geile Nummer. Das Thema müssen wir gleich mal hier aufsteigen. Vor zwei Jahren war ja die Seidenstraße der Knaller hier.
Da kommt er wieder.
Gib alles!
Los!
Das Teil steht glaube ich scheiße.
Das Teil kommt da einfach nicht.
Da ist aber ein Knick in der Leitung.
Wir müssen den Knick entfernen.
Muss der auswurfen.
Unsere bezaubernde Assistentin Claudia.
Zwischenapplaus für Claudia, die Sendezentrum.
Du hast ja gestern schon geöffnet. Gib mal einen her, ich will auch mal einen öffnen. Das ging ja einfach. Was war hier? Seitwärts kippen war das? Ich hab mir das gemerkt.
Für weitere Sendungen.
Das ist alles für mich.
Es muss nur gerade sein hier, dann funktioniert das auch. Wir könnten das Ding auch mal, ich finde das blinkt so schön. Wollen wir das nicht mal auf die Bühne stellen? Weil es sieht ja sonst keiner.
Es wird sogar nur während Sendungen verwendet.
Cool, sogar wenn der Deckel auf ist, hört's auf zu...
Nee, doch nicht. Die ganze Stromgeschichte muss natürlich mitgehen. Aber so ist schon mal besser, wa?
Sorry, es geht nicht bei jedem.
Kannst du direkt aufs Publikum... Gibt's eigentlich noch diese Grashotline dieses Jahr?
Also gestern gab's die, nee, war kein Gras.
Grashotline?
Also bei dem ersten Mal, Seidenstraße, sollte man sich auch grünes oder braunes per Rohrpost schicken lassen.
Was war denn da jetzt drin? Wir haben ganz tief in die Kuh reingefasst, und es kam etwas braunes heraus.
Also Nougat, Joghurt, Knusperkeks.
Ich setz aus, ich trinke.
Mit knusprigen Cornflakes. Ja, die Seidenstraße, also war ja sehr impressive. Und dann letztes Jahr dachte ich so, jetzt lässt es nach. Und dann war es auf dem Camp gar nicht.
Oder fast nicht.
Irgendwie war es nicht wirklich da. Und ich finde, diesmal haben sie ein großes Comeback gestartet. Also wer das noch nicht mitbekommen hat, es gibt mindestens zwei essenzielle Verbesserungen.
Ne, drei.
Einen Router.
Ja, das ist zwei. Also was ich schon erstmal beeindrucken finde, ist, dass dieses Problem der überall verteilten, lautstärkeverbreitenden Staubsauger dahingehend gelöst wurden, dass man das Ganze einfach auf zwei Staubsauger reduziert hat. Wir stehen an einem zentralen Ort. Genau, die Cloud ist direkt hinter dieser Bühne im Übrigen.
Staubsauger in the Cloud.
Genau, Staubsauger in the Cloud. Staubsauger as a Service sozusagen. Und die saugen dann so vor sich hin.
Das ist auch S-R-A-S.
Staubsauger as a Service. Und das sind ja diese, also ich weiß nicht, ob man die Industrie-Staubsauger nennen kann. Kann man die Industrie-Staubsauger nennen?
Gewerbestaubsauger.
Industrie-Gewerbe.
Ja, Industrie-Gewerbe-Staubsauger as a Service. Und die haben ja den Vorteil, dass die können ja saugen und blasen. Weiß schon, es saugt und bläst, ja.
Heinzelmann?
War es sonst nur der? Ah, fast!
Die ist für mich jetzt, ich weiß es.
Okay, ich kann deine Schokolade haben, ne?
Also die können halt saugen und blasen und haben halt zwei entsprechende Anschlüsse. Und es sind jeweils zwei Staubsauger. Es gibt nur zwei Staubsauger, die sind parallel geschaltet. Und die beiden Saugstutzen sind halt zusammengefasst in ein Rohr und die beiden Blaststutzen sind zusammengefasst in ein Rohr. Das ergibt eine Kombination aus zwei Saugblaststutzen. Diese werden dann wiederum per Rohr, hören wir überhaupt noch einer zu?
Natürlich, wie immer.
Werden per Rohr aus diesem Raum herausgeleitet in das Zentrum. Wahrscheinlich auch irgendein Ock, Silk-Ock oder so. Hier heißt ja alles Ock.
Slock?
Ja, lassen wir das. Auf jeden Fall kommen die da halt sozusagen an. Und dann gibt es dann halt das Patch-Panel für die Primärverteilung. Wenn du also jetzt hier etwas ans Sendezentrum schicken willst, dann nimmst du hier dieses Behältnis, tust wertvolle Dinge rein. Und dann nimmst du halt entweder das Saugrohr oder das Blasrohr. In dem Fall das Blasrohr. Vollkommen neue Bedeutung für ein Blasrohr. Und das steckst du dann halt einfach in den Stutzen, der hier herführt. Was aber dann noch nicht dazu führen würde, dass hier was rauskommt, weil es muss ja dann auch noch, zweites Feature, das läuft gut. Hier, Roddy, für dich.
Ich versuch grad, das zu komponieren.
Ich glaub, die Sendung war nicht für uns.
Sicher? Alles, was hier ankommt, ist für uns.
Guck mal, hier ist mit Notenlinien und dann kann man was reinstanzen. Wie mach ich das auf?
Waren das jetzt schon die drei neuen Features, Timme?
Bitte?
Waren das schon die drei neuen Features?
Zwei hab ich, glaub ich, bisher.
Okay, dann bist du ja gleich fertig.
Ja, also ich hab noch lange nicht fertig. Also, Staubsauger as a Service und dann Router. Und der Router ist hier vorne und das ist so eine kleine Drehscheibe, die von so einem Arduino, Raspberry, keine Ahnung, irgendwas gesteuert wird und fernsteuerbar ist. Nicht über Ethernet, wie man vielleicht denken möchte, sondern über Klingeldraht, die dann irgendein Cannibus-artiges Serial-Dirivat überwacht.
Wie viele Leute haben gestern NSFW gehört hier?
Paar.
Die kennen die Geschichte alle schon.
Also das dritte Feature ist... Das hab ich nicht erzählt.
Oh, jetzt die Specials nur in unserer Sendung.
Wenn du eine zentrale Saugblaseinheit hast, die nur von einer einzigen Stelle aus bedient werden kann, die ja auch die Fernbedienung haben für die Staubsauger, dass sie überhaupt saugen oder pasen. Wie schaffst du es jetzt zum Beispiel? Also angenommen, wir würden jetzt etwas zurücksenden wollen. Wir könnten jetzt zum Beispiel unsere Schunkresse da reinkippen und das dann hier so reinmachen. Wie verlässt das dann hier sozusagen wieder den Ort?
Na früher mussten wir noch mal reinbrüllen, haben jetzt auf der anderen Seite gehört und haben dann eingeschaltet.
Genau.
Und jetzt gibt's... Das ist alles per IP und das...
Und jetzt, nee, jetzt gibt's Feldtelefone. Hier stehen Feldtelefone dran und da kannst du dann schön dein... Dann drehst du am Rad.
Und dann wird...
Guck mal, komische Geräusche raus. Mensch, dein erstes Konzert hier in Live in the Freak Show. Du machst das gut. Man dreht am Rad. Und dann nimmt halt da unten die Vermittlungsstelle ab und sagt halt irgendwie, ja, hier Chaos-Seidenstraße.
Da ist dein Feldtelefon.
Da ist das Feldtelefon, genau. Soll ich das jetzt benutzen oder was?
Ich komponiere mal was schneller.
Darf ich das jetzt so nehmen oder fällt das dann gleich alles runter?
Aber mein Vorschlag für die Seidenstraße wäre ja, dass der Auswurfpunkt der tiefste Punkt von dem Rohr ist. Also zumindest am Ende, weil das bleibt immer da unten hängen. Und wenn sie das da ein bisschen anheben würden, dann würde es nur noch rausfallen können.
Aber auf dich hört ja keiner.
Nee, genau, mich hat da wieder keiner gefragt.
Wollen wir ein bisschen Konfetti schicken von der Bühne?
Geil.
Ich bereite da mal was vor.
Warte mal, ich muss das machen. Ich muss das dann so machen.
Ist das richtig?
Also Tim, jetzt werden schon die Felge...
Aber schön zu machen, sonst gibt es eine Sauerei.
Wenn die das Rohr aufmachen.
Können wir nicht ein bisschen loses Konfetti durchpusten?
Ja, ist vielleicht nicht so cool. Hat das schon funktioniert?
Warte, da kommt gerade noch was an. Hier, guck mal, es gibt eine Konfetti-Box.
Wo ist denn der Abspieler?
Ja, hier, auf den Schoß.
Hallo, Vermittlung.
Hier einmal Konfetti zum Abschicken.
Ich bin wieder dran.
Das funktioniert alles nicht hier.
Macht das falsch rum?
Zwei Sekunden machen das locker.
Hallo.
Die hören alle Freak Show und heben sich ab.
Mehr Metal.
Hallo.
Funktioniert nicht. Vielleicht könnt ihr ja mal Kontakt herstellen. Ich hab da kein Zeichen für jetzt. Na ja, ist auf jeden Fall geil.
So geil wie Flora Power-Mate.
Du hast jetzt mich gefragt, was ich so mache. Jetzt ist die Frage, was macht ihr eigentlich hier so außer Rumlungern? Weil ich arbeite ja.
Außer Rumlungern jetzt noch?
Moment, ich komponiere.
Ich lunger rum.
Also außer Rumlungern, ich fahr mit dem Roller rum.
Genau, also wie sieht unser Kongresstag aus? Das ist eigentlich auch eine schöne Episode für die Freak Show. Die individuellen Kongresstage. Also Dennis zählt Geld, ich lunger rum.
Wann ging es denn los bei dir heute?
Mit dem Rumlungern.
Feedback. Was ist hiermit eigentlich?
Zurückschicken.
Ich kann ja hier keine Ansagen machen. Hier klingelt irgendwas.
Hallo?
Das war ich glaube ich.
Hallo.
Wer möchte die Komposition?
Ich kann ein Feldtelefon überhaupt nicht benutzen.
Das ist zu echt.
Ich erzähl nie wieder was vom Krieg.
Warst du nicht, haben sie nicht gedient?
Guck mal hier unser Basswort-Bingo.
Zurückschicken. Ihr macht das hier schon, ne?
Können wir hier vielleicht mal einen Assistenten haben? Ist das hier auch gerade wieder gekommen? Ich verlier langsam den Überblick. So, wer hat denn jetzt schon Star Wars geguckt?
Ich.
Einige. Das heißt, der Rest hat alles kein Star Wars geguckt. Und? Wollen wir jetzt den Spaß verderben?
Welchen Spaß?
Nein, wir sind ja freundlich und machen sowas nicht. Aber man muss ja trotzdem darüber reden, weil es hat ja schon einen gewissen Impact.
Darth Vader ist gar nicht sein Vater?
Also ich hab ihn gesehen und Rolly auch.
Ja.
Ich hab ihn auf Deutsch, leider, in 2D gesehen, Gott sei Dank. Und du?
Ich hab den Worst Case, also Deutsch und 3D.
Also, ich fand jetzt das Deutsch nicht so schlecht, aber.
Das ist, also da muss man echt mal sagen, dieses IMAX-Kino wirbt damit irgendwie hier so 4K, 5K Leinwand. Irgendwie super scharfes Bild, und dann kriegst du diese bekloppte 3D-Brille. Dann ist alles Milchglas.
Unscharf und dunkel.
Unscharf und Teile ragen aus dem Bild raus, wo sie nicht hingehören. Und irgendwie.
Das ist ein Medienbruch.
Und es tut auf der Nase weh.
Das Schöne ist übrigens bei dieser Live-Sendung, dass man endlich die Hörerschaft befragen kann. Wir erzählen die ganze Zeit ins Mikrofon. Wir wissen eigentlich gar nicht, oder wir tuten ins Mikrofon, ob das, was wir erzählen, mit der Hörerschaft resoniert oder nicht. Natürlich kann man denken, wenn es nicht so wäre, würden die nicht hören. Aber ich bin ja auch prominenter 3D-Kino-Verweigerer oder Kino-Verweigerer. Aber in dem Fall würde ich das auf 3D-Kino beschränken. Und jetzt auch hier mal kurz die Umfrage. Wer findet denn 3D-Kino richtig geil?
Oh, doch 4.
Nö, das ist mehr.
Ich würde mal sagen, jetzt mal so locker 20. Und wer findet es explizit ungeil?
Deutlich mehr.
So 99 Prozent.
Meine Hörer.
Meine Hörer. Ja, aber mal ehrlich, ich meine irgendwie, das Bild ist dunkel, unscharf, schwierig.
Du musst.
Also ich stimme dir vollkommen zu. Ich finde, diese ganze 3D-Geschichte, die bringt irgendwie nichts.
Will keiner? Du musst.
Es nimmt ja kein Ende hier.
Was mit dem Gras?
Wieso war da schon wieder keins drin oder was?
Nee.
Den hatten wir da schon. Den kannst du wieder reinschmeißen, die gehen automatisch zurück. Irgendwann saugen die auch mal.
Meinst du?
Ja, haben die ja gerade auch gemacht. Ich hab ja schon drei zurückgeschickt.
Kann ich das hier reinstecken?
Ja, einfach reinstecken.
Ihr hört ja wahrscheinlich den Ström und dann müsst ihr jetzt einfach mal den Heinzelmann auf Saugen stellen. Jetzt haben wir schon wieder diese Off-Stimme, die einen total aufbringt.
Hat das geklappt? Siehst du, die hören den Strom.
Vollkommen modern networking. Ihr könnt euch schon ruhig mal mit auf den Kanal schalten, sonst funktioniert das nicht, wenn ihr uns einfach nur so ins Ohr redet.
Was wir sollen ankündigen, dass die Streams in wenigen Minuten ausfallen. Was ist denn das?
Jahrhundert.
Techniker ist informiert. Die Streams werden in wenigen Minuten ausfallen und ihr könnt euch dann irgendwo beschweren.
Bei Danimo.
Aber nicht bei uns.
E-Mail kommt später. Ich hab hier vier Themen gewürfelt. Mit den Themenwürfeln. Haben wir noch Themen war der erste Würfel. Der zweite war Kapitelmarken. Der dritte Erlang und der vierte war Riecht nach Lulu.
Was ist das denn?
Ich kam gerade mit der Post.
Ach, Freak Show Themenwürfel. Kannst du das mal ein bisschen genauer beschreiben? Was du in der Hand hältst.
Ich hab die auch gerade erst bekommen. Also man kann die würfeln und dann steht da Zeug drauf. Zum Beispiel Otto Normal Face Tuber oder Oper erzählt vom Krieg.
Das gilt aber alles nicht als Bingo-Karte. Genau, das ist so einfach. Das ist nicht so einfach.
Dann zittert das natürlich. Oder es ist ja auf allen immer das Gleiche. Es sind immer der gleiche Würfel, ist ja lame.
Also wenn du das jetzt alles vorliest, dann devaluierst du hier das Bingo, ist das klar? Das ist nicht immer das Gleiche.
Aber warum kriegen wir als Nerds einen 6-seitigen Würfel? Die Würfel-Evolution, die Würfel-Forschung hat ja irgendwie schon irgendwie, was weiß ich, 4-seitige Würfel erdacht. Und die Freak Show ist ja nun wirklich nicht auf 6 Themen limitiert.
Ja, aber auf ein 6 wird es...
Aber auf 5!
Es passt mehr drauf auf so einen Würfel.
Der kann nicht überkoppeln.
Also ist ja kein Wunder, dass das mit dem Empire nichts geworden ist.
Aber kommen wir noch mal zurück zu 3D. Vielleicht können wir die Kritik ja noch mal ein bisschen genauer fassen.
Ist scheiße.
Ja.
Roddy hat getrunken heute.
Entschuldigung.
Ja, so geht es ja nun nicht.
Ja, aber ich meine, es war doch eine Zusammenfassung, die irgendwie alles erfasst.
Also ich kann ja mal versuchen, das Ganze ein bisschen argumentativ zu untermauern. Also es nimmt einfach vor allem erstmal Auflösung und Blickfeld.
Und Schärfe.
Und Schärfe. Also es nimmt eigentlich alles, was Kino ausmacht. Oder sagen wir mal, was so primäre Erlebnisfaktoren sind von Kino, die da einfach weggenommen werden.
Ja, besonders wenn du Brillenträger bist, dann siehst du halt wirklich nicht mehr das ganze Bild, weil du hast ja noch eine Brille über der Brille. Und dann guckst du in so ein Bullauge rein.
Ja, ist so ein bisschen, als wenn du so in ein Luftkurort ankommst, und dann kriegst du erstmal ein Röhrchen zum Atmen zugesteckt, so durch den Strohhalm.
Ist auch 4K-Luft, also.
Also 3D resoniert bei mir irgendwie auch nicht so richtig. Aber trotzdem sind manche Leute davon beeindruckt. Ich hab, glaub ich, in meinem Leben einen 3D-Film bisher gesehen. Also ich hab wirklich eine extrem breite Datenbasis.
Das eigentliche Problem an 3D ist ja, dass du Dreidimensionales sehen, durch die Parallaxe, den Abstand der beiden Augen, nur in deinem eigentlichen, was du so manipulativ noch erreichen kannst. Also in dem Meter funktioniert das. Alles andere funktioniert nur noch über Größe und was das Hirn sonst noch so weiß. Das heißt, alles, was du in 3D auch wirklich nahe siehst, hast du dann immer mitten in der Fresse. Und ich will nicht die Ecke von irgendeinem Raumschiff in der Fresse haben. Was soll die Scheiße?
Sei froh, wenn's nur ein Raumschiff ist, was du in der Fresse hast, ja.
Solche Filme guck ich nicht.
Zumindest nicht in 3D.
Also, wer richtig Spaß haben will, muss mal den Film von Gaspar Noé gucken, den Love, das ist toll in 3D.
Ich wollte schon grad das Thema auf Pornos bringen.
Das ist kein Porno.
Wir sind schon dumm.
Aber es ist schon so, da wird schon rumgemacht.
Wieso haben wir eigentlich keine Pornokarte im Bingo?
Naja, weil es ja da rechts unten ist, mit das System wartet, wartet...
Reden wir zu wenig über Pornos.
Wir reden temporär, geduldig auf ihre Vorschläge. Das sind ja nur Sachen, über die wir häufiger reden. Dabei ist Porno wirklich sehr interessant. Also als Thema meint es so. Und mir ist noch nicht ganz klar, welchen Impact 3D-Kino hat für Porno.
Das...
Ich will es nicht wissen.
Oh Gott, hier sind ja schon zwei.
Und einer hängt noch in der Röhre. Ich will auch mal wieder einen haben.
Ja, hier.
So, ich hab übrigens noch einen Liebesbrief bekommen.
Steht hier.
Liebesbrief an Freak Show FM.
Liebe Freaks.
Eine Frage. Was wünscht ihr euch vom Internet? Das ist jetzt ernst gemeint. Nur ernst gemeinte Zuschriften. Wie kann unser digitaler Raum lebenswerter werden?
Ach je.
Weißt du, wir sollen jetzt sozusagen von unserem Modus abweichen hier und uns mal wirklich Gedanken machen?
Ja, ich prange ja auch eigentlich generell immer Leute an, die sich nur beschweren und aber nicht weiterdenken und einen Verbesserungsvorschlag haben. Aber ich finde, in der Freak Show machen wir das eigentlich immer ganz gut.
Ja.
Deswegen, wenn du jetzt diese Frage beantworten willst, dann also...
Die weiteren Sendungen verschieben sich auch.
Make it count.
Was wünsche ich mir vom Internet?
Aber das ist ja total unrealistisch, sich was vom Internet zu wünschen, weil die User, die Facetuber oder wie heißt das?
Otto Normal Facetuber.
Otto Normal Facetuber, zu denen wir ja auch gehören. Wir entscheiden ja die ganze Zeit mit unserem Nutzerverhalten.
Ich wünsche mir mehr Qualität und weniger Spam.
Dann musst du das mit deinem Nutzerverhalten zum Ausdruck geben.
Und mehr Bandbreite. Wir reden übers Internet, Alter.
Ja, eben.
Naja, ich meine, das Internet ist ja an sich wir alle. Von daher kann man sich vom Internet eigentlich gar nichts wünschen. Aber ich glaube, die Frage geht eher so ein bisschen in Richtung, was würde man gerne sehen, dass das Internet so als Medium hervorbringen lässt.
Aber das ist ja das Problem. Und der Congress heißt ja Gated Communities. Und genau das passiert ja jetzt im Internet. Alles wird so zur Plattform zusammengeschlossen, alles wird eingegrenzt.
Und wir Fanboys sind ja schuld.
Und die Freak Show-Hörer sind ja noch die einzigen quasi, die verstehen können, wie das Internet wirklich funktioniert und es dann auch entsprechend nutzen. Nicht alles in die Cloud schieben und so weiter. Aber das ist ja leider die Minderheit. Das heißt, alle anderen schieben alles in die Cloud und so weiter. Und dann, also was will man da vom Internet noch haben?
Okay, noch eine Umfrage wieder. Wer hat iCloud und nutzt das aber nicht? So viel dazu, Hucke. Alles in der Cloud.
Das musst du übersetzen, weil das sieht man ja nicht im Bild.
Wer hat seinen eigenen Web-Server?
Muss das quantifizieren?
Da haben sich ganz schön viele gemeldet.
Ab wo beginnt Eigen?
Na ja, so du hast Web-Space.
Irgendwo geklickt?
Du hast nicht einen Tumbler, sondern du hast dir Web-Space geklickt, das WordPress selber installiert.
Du hast HTML-Seiten. Selber per FDP hochgeladen.
Web-Fuchs.
Ja, aber ich meine, das ist wirklich so dieses ganze Wissen, wie man eigentlich in dieses Internet reinschreibt, das geht irgendwie mehr und mehr verloren. Die Leute wissen nur noch, wie man Eingabemasken befüllt. Keiner weiß, wie man selber mal, also jetzt hier natürlich anwesend ausgeschlossen, insofern ist halt schwierig, was man noch vom Internet will. Ich will ganz viel vom Internet, aber ich weiß auch, das wird nicht passieren.
Das mit dem Keiner ist ja so eine Sache. Also ich denke, dass absolut gesehen die Zahl von Leuten, die eine Menge rausholt aus dem Netz, einfach deutlich höher ist als vor 20 Jahren, weil einfach mehr Leute daran teilnehmen.
Ja, aber zum Beispiel sowas wie Wikipedia oder OpenStreetMap, das ist jetzt auch schon, wie viele Dekaden her, dass das kam. Und seitdem, was ist danach nochmal gekommen, was die Grundfesten der Gesellschaft ähnlich verändert hat?
Seit Wikipedia?
Ja, oder OpenStreetMap oder ähnlich revolutionäre Webprojekte usw. Ja, da ist nämlich relativ dünn plötzlich.
Na ja, also Facebook hat das schon getan, das ist es nicht.
Aber zum Beispiel Wikipedia, also auf der Webseite von Y Combinator, diesem Angel Investor-Dingspumst, da steht ja seit eh und je Ideas we like to fund, English, nee, English. Und da steht, due to Wikipedia, what Wikipedia did to Encyclopedia Britannica. Also das würden die gerne funden und bezahlen, aber es macht halt auch keiner.
Ja, ist schwierig, ich meine...
Harte Knaller!
Ach so, vielleicht musst du es andersrum halten. Sag mal.
Der Trick ist nämlich, die Sendung ist total fremd. Sonst haben die keine Leerbehälter. Wenn die keine Leerbehälter mehr haben, können die keinen Nachschub schicken. Das ist wie in einer Bar. Ab und zu rösten die Gläser mal zurück. Habe ich schon zurückgeschickt, alle.
Hast du auch schon Chunk getrunken oder was?
Jetzt bin ich wieder dran.
Also früher war mehr Gras.
Schoki, Getränke, Moorschoki und noch mehr Getränke.
Ich sehe da hat irgendjemand das Monopol auf die Seitenstraßenleitung.
Wir sind nicht safe for work.
Bevor wir jetzt überziehen, können wir ja vielleicht auch noch mal ein bisschen über den Kongress gehen. Ist noch eine Viertelstunde.
Ja, da kommt die Kongress-Rakete.
Oh, in Fairy Dust we trust. Kann ich das irgendwie rausnehmen? Soll ich das irgendwie rausnehmen? Soll ich anbeißen?
Sind das die Freak Show Ultras da hinten eigentlich?
Freak Show Ultras, endlich im Bild. Aber ich bin so blöd. Kannst du das mal hier?
Ich muss jetzt mal, warte.
Was?
Du weißt Bescheid? Ich hab nämlich die Freak Show Ultras noch nie gesehen. Ich hab sie nur auf dem Twitter gesehen. Und jetzt?
Die haben uns diese Flasche Teufelszeug.
Die können wir jetzt mal weg exen, oder? Das Teufelszeug.
Ah, du hast einfach alles entzogen.
Filme für die Ultras.
Ja, was ist das überhaupt?
Und wieder in mein Getränk voll.
David, wenn du hier bist, einer ist für dich.
Wo ist denn David?
David, wo bist du denn?
Du bist doch hier irgendwo, oder?
Wir lassen hier einen in der Flasche.
Ist der nicht da?
Da?
Wo, wo, wo, wo?
Da komm mal her, komm mal her.
Mach mal David auch noch mal einen.
Hier ist schon einer, hier ist schon einer. Es waren schon fünf.
Wir wissen schon, David, Previously David.
Previously David, jetzt.
Ich hab schon.
Runter das Zeug.
Oh, geil.
Ich stehe ja total drauf, so was. Ist das nicht so ein Klon von dem Original?
Mexikaner ist doch...
Dazu muss man sagen...
Wie heißt denn das Original noch mal?
Ich hab ja mal ein halbes Jahr in Hamburg gewohnt. Und wenn man Hamburg auf ein Getränk reduzieren will, dann heißt das Mexikaner. Das ist so das Zeug, was man 3 Uhr nachts in jedem Club irgendwie kriegt und trinkt. Ich weiß nicht, es gehört irgendwie dazu. Ich weiß auch nicht wieso.
Das ist doch die einzige Art von Tomatensaft, die man auf der Erde trinkt, ne?
Tomatensaft trinkt...
Du hast den Parabelflug gemacht, nicht wir.
Du hast da auch Tomatensaft.
Gott sei Dank nicht.
Das Hamburger Mundfeuerwerk. Herzhafte Tomatenspiratose mit fein gemahlenen Chilischoten. Kräftig schütteln.
Habt ihr das gemacht?
Klar.
Natürlich hab ich geschüttelt.
Ich find das super.
Ich schüttel immer. Genau. Lass mal die Hörer...
Nimm die ganze Flasche, Dennis.
Und dann verteilen, ne?
Ich will auch noch was.
Und wer, du trinkst keinen.
Ja, einen nehm ich auch noch.
Okay, ist euch jetzt außer der Seidenstraße noch irgendein anderes... Also ich meine, wir müssen ja auch... Wir haben ja ein bisschen...
Was haben wir?
Die Pflicht der Berichterstattung, ja?
Ich hab das, mein bisher tollstes Fundstück auf dem Kongress war ein Mensch, vielleicht ist er ja auch hier irgendwo, der hat einen Plastikkoffer gehabt und hat ihn vor uns ausgebreitet und da drin war ein Metallgestänge mit irgendwelchen Tastern dran und MIDI-Kabeln. Und was das dann am Ende war, war eine E-Flöte und es hat auch einen Schlauch und einen Drucksensor und wenn man reinpustet, hat dieser Drucksensor gemessen, also wie doll man da reinpustet und die Töne waren bitcodiert. Also es gab eine Anleitung, wo Bitpatterns für Oktaven, Halbtöne und generelle Tonverschiebungen irgendwie gab. Und ich dachte mir, wow, okay, also ein Nerd, der Flötenspieler ist und jetzt eine E-Flöte baut und dann stellte sich aber raus, er hat eigentlich gar keine Ahnung von Musik und auch nicht vom Flöte spielen, schon erst recht nicht, aber er hatte Bock, dieses Instrument zu bauen und sucht jetzt sozusagen hier auf dem Congress jemand, der seine E-Flöte spielen will.
Willst du mal auf meiner E-Flöte spielen?
Ja, also so einfach irgendwie sich mit der Materie ausgesetzt, ohne irgendwelches Hintergrundwissen und ich bau jetzt eine E-Flöte und ich kodier das in Bits und ich mach das und es funktioniert, kann man hier auf dem Congress finden, falls jemand ein passionierter Bitflöten-Spieler ist. Oder werden will. Also ihr habt ja auch gesehen, vielleicht in der Lounge, da hat ja vorhin einer Musik gemacht, der hatte seinen ganzen Drum-Beat mit tatsächlich physischen, motorgesteuerten Drums. Wer hat das von euch gesehen?
Also wirklich Leute.
Wir sind nicht so wie du, 24,5 in der Lounge.
Ich sag euch so als Rummellunge rauf im Congress, sieht man auch ganz schöne Sachen. Vor allen Dingen andere Sachen.
Ja, das Lounge-Programm heute zum Beispiel.
Oder gestern oder auch morgen.
Das fasst ihr gerade.
Was habt ihr alles verpasst? Einfach nur in Erwartung, hier einen Sitzplatz zu bekommen. Habt ihr zum Beispiel Incredible Herringgedeck verpasst. Ich übrigens auch. Weil ich war ja noch bei den Kollegen vom Anycast eingeladen.
Aber das Herringgedeck wurde auch auf dem Camp aufgezeichnet. Also man kann es noch nachschauen.
Ich musste ja Bierpong spielen. Und hab verloren.
Ja, das hab ich gehört.
Warum? Ich hab halt nicht getroffen.
Kannst du mal erklären, was es ist?
Das wissen die jungen Leute da draußen alle, was Bierpong ist.
Okay, man stelle sich vor.
Warte, umfrage. Wer weiß nicht, was Bierpong ist?
Okay, ich hab euch beiden erklärt.
Oder du hast einfach nur einige Partys.
Ich wollte ja nur helfen.
Ich wusste es auch nicht, sonst hätte ich nicht ja gesagt.
Ich bin halt auf so einem Helfer-Trip. Ich hab auch noch was für euch.
Iberogast oder Closafromelissengeist?
Nee, das ist ziemlich wichtig.
Auch im Congress hab ich mir sagen lassen. Und zwar Homeda-Elektrosmog-C30.
Na, das sind so Globuli.
Ja, ich bin auch welche. Das sind bestimmt lecker.
Mehr, aber dann wirkt es doch weniger.
Ja, aber eine Unterdosierung ist echt gefährlich.
Ja, aber mal richtig reinhauen hier. Ist geil.
Hat auch Zucker drin übrigens. Also eigentlich nur.
Ja, jetzt bin ich entspannt.
Wo ist denn der Mexikaner jetzt eigentlich hin? Den habt ihr jetzt irgendwie komplett weggeschickt, den Mexikaner, oder was?
Ist da noch was drin, oder habt ihr den geext?
Der ist leer.
Ihr seid so passdoffen.
Endlich schmeckt mir hier mal was.
Wir können ja nachher noch einen saufen.
Dennis, hast du auch schon so einen Moment gehabt?
Wobei?
Na, beim Congress.
Was war der größte Schein, den du gezählt hast?
500er.
Ich hab 500er bezahlt, und dann war vorhin einer mit einem 100er an der Garderobe, hab ich gehört.
Okay, Garderobe ist ein gutes Stichwort. Also, wenn es irgendwas auf dem Congress gibt, wo ich sagen würde, das ist ein bisschen over-ingeniert, also vielleicht so ein Mühe, ne? Also das Garderomensystem wäre ein heißer Kandidat für...
Abschaffen.
Warum?
Weil man seine Jacke einfach hier hinschmeißt.
Hier kommt nichts weg.
Das ist natürlich noch die andere Variante. Aber irgendwie, also dieses Bong-System, erst mal ausdrücken.
Bong-System. Wie man muss erst rauchen, bevor man seine Jacke abgeben kann.
Aber irgendwie, ich vermisse halt auch so die ganzen verpeilten Kassenengel irgendwie. Die sind jetzt alle so auf Software. Und das fühlt sich so an wie das SAP der Garderoben-Software. Also ohne dem Schaffer da zu nahe treten zu wollen. Das war sicherlich alles mit guten Ideen und so, aber...
Aber die haben ein elektronisches System für...
Hast du das noch nicht gesehen? Du gehst an die Garderobe, du sagst eine Jacke, dann drucken sie dir einen Zettel, zwei Zettel aus, auf einen Kassenbonddrucker, dann hängen sie einen an die Jacke und geben dir einen. Wenn du das abholen willst, gehst du an die selbe Stelle, sagst, diesen Zettel abholen. Sie scannen den Barcode und sagen dir, an Platz Nummer 2 empfängt dich jetzt gleich deine Jacke. Und dann gehst du da hin und wartest, dass der... Naja, man muss fairerweise sagen, ich hab bisher an der Garderobe noch nicht so lange warten müssen. Vielleicht funktioniert es auch wirklich einfach toll, aber ich dachte mir echt nach... Also muss das sein? Ist es kostenlos? Nee, es kostet auch einen Euro, aber...
Hast du da noch Mate?
Also für alle, die das Garderomensystem noch nicht erfahren haben, guckt euch das mal an.
Haben wir noch Eis?
Nee, aber noch Rum.
Ja eben.
Hat von euch schon jemand Bingo?
Wie sieht es denn aus?
Drogen ist übrigens freigegeben.
Wir haben schon die Hälfte der Themen.
Wer hätte es gedacht?
Aber wenn man sich mal anschaut, worüber wir noch nicht geredet haben, das sagt auch eine Menge aus, oder? Die ganzen Klassiker.
Ich habe schon lange keine Post mehr gekommen.
Ich weiß nicht, vielleicht ist ja irgendwas gekommen. Ich weiß nicht.
Noch eine wichtige Frage. Es ist immer wieder so, dass die Leute, die das erste Mal auf dem Congress sind, die finden ja bestimmte Orte einfach nicht selbstständig. Es gibt zwar die tollen...
Auch Leute, die schon das dritte Mal auf dem Congress sind.
Ja, das stimmt auch. Es gibt zwar die tollen Chaos-Partinnen. Wer sich dafür nicht interessiert hat bisher, hat einen großen Fehler gemacht und das erste Mal da war. Kann ich nur empfehlen. Wer von euch ist das erste Mal auf dem Congress?
Aber hallo!
Wir müssen das qualifizieren.
40%?
Herzlichen Glückwunsch. Ihr habt die richtige Entscheidung getroffen.
Oder 30. Jetzt die andere Frage.
Herzlichen Glückwunsch. Ihr habt endlich die richtige Entscheidung getroffen.
What took you so long?
Wer hat schon mehr als 5 Kongresse? Wird schon dünner.
10?
Keiner mehr als 10?
Doch, der da drüben.
Und Timme, wo ist dein Arm? 5, 10?
Also dann raus.
Okay, wer von euch war noch nicht in der Lounge? Also wer weiß nicht, was die Party Lounge ist, wo Konzerte und so weiter stattfinden.
Also die Disse.
In der Halle.
Lassen unsere Leute wissen Bescheid. Auch die Erstlinge waren schon in der Lounge, weil das ist wirklich ein Ort, den man nicht verpassen sollte. Und wer noch nicht da war, vor dem Tunnel zum Hackcenter links einfach auf die Tür zu laufen? Da findet ihr auch mich.
Ich hatte eine andere Frage erwartet.
Wo das Gras hin soll.
Jetzt fragen wir nochmal. Und zwar die Leute, die gesagt haben, erster Kongress. Wer von euch ist jetzt wegen Podcasts oder wegen diesem Podcast hierher gekommen?
Ist gar nicht so wichtig hier der Podcast.
Wer hätte es gedacht?
Ihr könnt uns zunächst so einen Stich lassen. Du trinkst den jetzt. Ist mir egal. Denn dahinter, da ist einer.
So, Radhi, ist dir was über den Weg gelaufen auf den Kongress, was irgendwie cool war?
Außer Bierpong.
Ich muss ehrlich sagen, nichts Neues. Wenn ich mich recht erinnere, will noch jemand Schokolade?
Timmy, der ist noch für dich, oder Pep, Lakritzlikör mit Pfeffer.
Ich will den, nein, ich will den nicht.
Nee, Radhi will den haben.
Also wer will den, das ist bestimmt tierisch eklig. Hast du nicht gerade einen?
Egal.
Dann nicht. Okay, dann hat es noch keinen.
Aber auf X.
Also ich finde ja, die Dekoration der Lounge finde ich ja mal wieder grandios.
Nur der Name passt mal wieder nicht.
Man hält schon nicht so lange aus neben der Bassbox.
Es ist einfach die Disse.
Es ist, nee.
Doch.
Ist auch nee.
Sondern?
Der Club.
Das Paradies.
Ich wäre für der Club. Weil, ist wie ein Club. Und ist ja dann sozusagen Club, Club, weiß schon, ne? Also passt ja irgendwie auch.
Der Club Club.
Der Club Club, der Club im Club.
C4.
Ja, das ist schon belegt. Das ist der Chaos Computer Club Kolon.
Aber das ist halt der Chaos Computer, ne? Chaos Communication Congress Club.
Vielleicht sollten wir uns mal einen anderen Buchstaben einfallen lassen.
Aber es gibt nur 25 weitere. Es ist nicht so einfach.
Es gibt ja noch Unicode.
Also, was man auf jeden Fall an dieser Stelle auch nochmal sagen muss. Wer von euch war denn auf dem Camp auch? Sehr gut, sehr gut, ja.
Du musst das quantifizieren.
Es sind für die Hörer da draußen 15 Prozent. Es ist so, in den Jahren, wo Congress und Camp zusammenfallen, ist es meistens so, dass das Orga-Team fast keine Pause hat.
Wait a minute, gibt es ein Jahr, wo die nicht zusammenfallen?
Drei.
Aber wenn ein Jahr, wo Camp ist, fällt es auch immer zusammen mit Congress.
Diese scheiß Klugscheißer-Nerds immer!
Hier einmal zurückschicken.
Also in den Jahren, wo Camp und Congress beide stattfinden, ist es halt für das Orga-Team auch immer ein tierischer Kampf. Das Camp wird abgebaut, abgerechnet, dann ist auch schon wieder Congress. Und früher war das auch so, dass man halt gemerkt hat, dass beim Congress dann im gleichen Jahr ein bisschen weniger Druck war. Und dieses Jahr hier merke ich das halt eigentlich nicht. Also der Kongress ist immer noch at full swing. Und 10 Applaus für das gesamte Orga-Team hier an dieser Stelle nochmal bitte.
Aber richtig.
Aber hallo.
Das ist wirklich wirklich geil.
Weil die sich so übers Kreuz ziehen, um diese Veranstaltung so schön zu machen. Das ist wirklich...
Das geht gar nicht. Ich hab das ja auch mal gemacht, aber so, das hätte ich mit den Schuhen nicht angezogen.
Hier einmal zurückschicken wieder.
Das war nur ein Ping, glaub ich.
Ja, das war ein W-Laden, irgendwas.
Das war nur ein Ping.
Also diese Seidenschrass, das funktioniert wirklich fantastisch.
Ja, außer das Gras.
Also ich war ja schon letzten Mittwoch hier und musste den Dom aufbauen. Oder ich hab den Dom aufgebaut. Und da hab ich schon so Stimmen gehört, die waren nicht so richtig begeistert hier vom Kongressaufbau, weil die meinten, ist nix zu tun. Alle machen so ihr Ding, man muss keine Anweisungen geben, es läuft wie von alleine und ist irgendwie so langweilig. Also die Leute, die eigentlich sonst so managen, immer die letzten Jahre, die standen so da und ja, es läuft alles. Die machen alles von alleine.
Hilfe, ich bin wichtig und werde nicht gebraucht.
Hast du noch ein Highlight gehabt, Dennis?
Nee, ich sitze ja im Hinterzimmer.
Eben bin ich so einem Typen begegnet, da standen wir doch zusammen. Der hatte irgendwie so eine Maske auf, wie so ein bisschen Phantom der Oper mäßig und das war offensichtlich so eine 3D-Brille. Wenn ich es richtig gedeutet habe, vorne mit einer Kamera aber schon noch mit drin, ne? Also, das ist auch geil.
Die Maske von Phantom der Oper ist eine 3D-Brille mit Kamera.
Ja, so in etwa.
Endlich verstehe ich das. Du eröffnest mir ganz neiga.
Phantom von Oper.
Aber er war so ein bisschen, er war so...
Wir sollten Dennis mehr Alkohol bei der Freak Show geben. Oder Globuli, man weiß es nicht.
Timme Post.
Wenn man dich erstmal von Elektrosmog abschirmt, Dennis, dann läuft's richtig.
So eine Anti-Elektrosmog. Zsunk, das ist schon geil.
Ich hab ja gestern NSFW geguckt und ich hab gesehen, komm, saufen bringt.
Das fällt dir aber später auf, Alter.
Und weil es uns Spaß macht, trinkt ihr das.
Dann gibt's jetzt aber keine Milch mehr für dich, ne?
Während der Freak Show unter dem Hinterlimmer.
Ein kleiner Klopfer.
Der war gar nicht so schlecht. Willst du noch die Hälfte? Und der andere geht raus. Oder will jemand?
Nee, nee, ich hau raus.
So, wo sind die Arme? Dennis, wo ist Dennis? Der hinter dir war schneller.
Also diese Leute, die so einen Scheiß nehmen und auch noch lenken, das hätte auch eine Wirkung.
Naja.
Für Kinder unzugänglich aufbewahren.
Hey, so Kinder auf Zuckerrausch, das ist irgendwie.
Nicht unterdosieren, wie gesagt, nicht unterdosieren. Das ist die einzige Gefahr. Krieg ich noch ein bisschen was? Mein Schunk ist nicht süß.
Elektrosmack.
Aber das müsste doch C32 sein.
Die tollen uns mit diesen.
Also wer uns diese Dinger geschickt hat, ja, Grundregel ist, eine Pfeife muss pfeifen können.
Das Mikrofon muss irgendwie.
Geht doch.
Das Mikrofon muss am Mund sein.
Ach, das ist falsch. Ich muss sagen, das ist das Süßeste, was ich auf dem Kongress je gesehen hab. Dennis versucht die Luftschlage zu pusten und sie tut es nicht.
Ja, ein leher Achtfehler.
So, ist die Bühne jetzt leer oder können wir noch was ins Publikum machen?
Na, wir haben die Stunde auf jeden Fall durch Pflicht gemacht.
Was? Alles weiter?
Ja, aber da kommt ja immer nur noch mehr.
Alk.
More of the same. Vor allem die sind die ganze Zeit dabei, ihre Jagd, Stolz, Alk.
Noch eine Stunde?
Eine Stunde noch, das Publikum ist auch besoffen.
Was?
Noch mehr Post.
Na, wenn das nicht ordnungsgemäß rausfällt. Ist das hier leer?
Ja, damit, mach die andere auf.
Hier, die wissen ja Bescheid, die beobachten uns. Da sind ja Videoüberwachungen, ne? Offen Kongress.
Ich darf? Partyknaller?
Hat eigentlich noch keiner Bingo?
Wie funktionieren hier so Partyknaller?
Wir reden ja bei dieser Freak Show, bei diesen Live-Shows, immer nur übers Trinken und Kongress, also da kommt man ja nicht weit.
Na ja, Klopfer? Ich find es gut.
Will ich den selber trinken? Selber oder ihr?
Scheiße.
Selber.
Oder du, okay.
Die schicken die ganze Zeit Scheiß, damit wir das mal selber schicken.
Was ist denn das? Küstenebel oder was?
Heißt das so?
Weiß ich doch nicht. Kleiner Klopfer Feige.
Das ist doch hier alles verrückt.
Schmeckt?
Wir können ja nicht aufhören, bevor hier nicht Gras durch die Seidenstraße kommt.
Da hinten sind noch Wundertüten für uns.
Noch eine.
Riesen Wundertüten. Kannst du mal eine aufmachen.
Tolle Überraschung.
Ja, wir geben was dabei.
Na gut, eine mach ich auf, wenn da kein Gras drin ist.
Dann streike ich hier.
Ein Förmchen, ah, für so viel Sand und keine Förmchen.
Hab ich euch schon gesagt, dass dieses MacBook Air einfach mal der geilste Computer, der es überhaupt gibt?
Ja, gleich nach meinem.
Ich meine, mit diesen ganzen Retina-Hips dann kannst du mich ja jagen.
Hier guck mal, eine 2D-Brille.
Ja, für den nächsten Kinobesuch.
Ich habe auch keine Retina, aber ich habe noch einen richtigen Computer mit Ethernet und so.
Ich habe Schwein gehabt.
Ich habe einen Nashorn und einen Wolf.
Ich habe ein Fußballspiel, das ist geil. Ein Fußballflipper habe ich hier.
Und ich habe eine Lupe, endlich kann ich wieder was lesen auf meinem Bildschirm.
20 habe ich.
Dennis, du mit Alkohol, dass ich das noch erleben darf.
Und Knusperl, das ist geil.
Kommt ihr nächstes Mal mit zur Union?
Union was?
Wenn wir wieder gewinnen.
Erste FC-Union in Berlin, wir haben zweimal gewonnen.
Christdemokratische?
Nee, nee, eine richtige Union.
Wer von euch ist aus Berlin?
Hälfte, was?
Und wer geht zur Union?
Naja, immerhin auch niemand.
Wer geht überhaupt zu Fußball? What is this Fußball anyway?
Ich sag dir, das Wissen um Fußball ist sozusagen noch eine gesellschaftliche Weiterentwicklungsstufe, die diese Szene auch durchaus noch mitnehmen kann.
Wenn wir so weit sind, können wir auch aufhören.
Die Nerds und Fußball, du denkst, dass das kompatibel ist? Hier, mach doch mal.
Da kommt ja immer das Gleiche. Denk doch immer was anderes aus.
Also früher auf dem Congress, ne?
Ja.
Da konnte man eine Decktelefonnummer anrufen.
Thema war Fußball.
Und dann gab es Fußballergebnisse.
Und dann gab es entweder einen Wodka-Shot oder Gras. Per Seidenstraße.
Der geht, hier.
Fußballergebnisse wäre doch mal ganz gut, oder?
Haben wir eigentlich noch Themen?
Nee, wir reden eigentlich nur noch um Kopf und Kragen. Bisher lief es ja noch ganz gut. Aber ich würde sagen jetzt...
Mit steigendem Alkoholfegel bei Herrn Ahrens und Herrn Roddy.
Noch mal feige.
Also ich...
Ihr dürft wieder abstimmen.
Wir können ja noch irgendwie...
Wer trinkt den? Selber? Ist ja einfach.
Wir können ja einfach auch Schluss machen.
Ich hab noch was. Hast du in den letzten Jahren, sagen wir so vor 5 und vorher, die haben sich immer beschwert, so der Frauenanteil stimmt hier irgendwie nicht richtig. Kannst du dir erinnern? Das war noch vor den ganzen Creeper-Cards und weiß-ich-nicht-alles. Kannst du dir erinnern? Naja, klar. Und hat sich noch mal wer beschwert dieses Jahr? Ist das noch Thema? Was schätzt du, was der Anteil ist?
Also ich kenn Stimmen, die sagen, der Frauenanteil wäre schon zu hoch, aber... Aber ich sag keine Namen.
Aber lass mich raten, es war eine Frau.
Ich sag keine Namen.
Aber wir sind auf einem Level angekommen, wo man sagen kann, es ist ungefähr, weil die perfekten 50 Prozent gibt's natürlich nicht, aber ich denke mal, es ist jetzt, man kann sagen, es ist okay.
Warum nicht?
Er hat ja auch getrunken. Das geht ja alles einher.
Aber ihr müsst euch mal vorstellen, vor 15 Jahren hättet ihr hier gesessen und ihr hättet, es wären nur Typen und vielleicht drei Frauen im ganzen Publikum. Ist so, oder?
Ja, war so.
Nur Typen auf der Bühne.
Vor der lieben Podcast, nur Typen auf der Bühne.
Wir quatschen schon wieder von dir.
Diese Stimme aus dem Off, Alter. Wir machen unsere Sendung so, wie wir wollen.
Genau, wir sind nämlich autark und autonom.
Aber, kurz schätzt. Also, tatsächlich ist es auch wie beim Camp so, dass die ganzen Leute, die ich hier wieder zum ersten Mal zum Congress geschleppt haben, dass die, das sind überwiegend leider auch Typen, muss ich zu meiner Stande gestehen, aber eine Studentin ist auch gekommen, immerhin. Aber auf jeden Fall haben die Typen auch gesagt, ja, sie wären auf jeden Fall überrascht, dass hier nicht nur Typen rumlaufen. Ich hätte ja, ich würde ja nicht 50-50 sagen, aber ich würde sagen...
Nee, hab ich nie gesagt. Ich hab auf einem Level gesagt, wo okay ist.
Aber ich würde sagen, es ist auf jeden Fall eine gute Entwicklung.
Ich hab irgendwie das Gefühl, wir sind auf dünnem Eis und irgendwie sollten wir das Gespräch nicht fortführen.
Mit beiden Beinen Fenster.
Aber ich stimme euch auf jeden Fall zu.
Wenn wir hier auf dünnem Eis sind, dann hätte die Sendung gestern mit Holger gar nicht stattfinden dürfen.
Naja, es fühlt sich normaler an.
Bitte was? Mehr über Max reden. Hab ich ja schon probiert, kam ja nicht an.
So ist ja nichts passiert, oder?
Nein, Tim wollte sein MacBook eher loben.
Hat jemand das neue Battery-Case eigentlich?
Fürs iPhone?
Keiner, okay.
Die Scheiße!
Nee, das bringt nichts. Komm, wir machen Schluss.
Ja, wir machen die Freak Show in der Lounge weiter.
Genau.
Im Club.
Genau, das machen wir.
Wir hören jetzt auf und dann spielen wir noch ein schönes Lied für euch. Und dann war's das irgendwie. Und wir bedanken uns ausgesprochen.
Komm, verneigen, verneigen. Wir verneigen uns vor unseren Hörern, denn ihr seid super.
Für die Fans. Hast du alle Knaller weggeknallt? Ah, dieser scheiß Creepy Steve immer.
Willst du's behalten?
Ja, die brauchen wir. Themenwürfel.